[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir je suis très heureux de vous
présenter pour la première fois ce soir
le nouveau jeune armand jammot des
chiffres et des lettres
comme tel constat c'est ce jeu est très
simple et je vais pas vous ennuyer trop
longtemps avec des explications un peu
fastidieuse en fait il reprend le
principe du mot le plus long que
beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent et ils
retrouveront j'espère avec plaisir mais
dans cette émission en mangea mots
associés au mot le plus long à nouveau
jeu de chiffres nous appellerons le
compte est bon et qui va nous permettre
de faire les opérations de calcul menthe
d'ailleurs je vais pas vous donner de
plus longues explications vous allez
découvrir ce jeu en jouant avec nous
qu'avec surtout avec le candidat quant à
dire qu'ils ont fait le plaisir de bien
vouloir inaugurait ce jeu et qui est
bien entendu maintenant on connaissent
parfaitement les règles cas il ne reste
plus qu'à tirer au sort je pense que je
peux me permettre de demander à ma cause
de choisir la première
phase
et bien c'est pile et c'est monsieur
pension qui va commencer tout de suite à
jouer avec nous or plus on pense aux
gens nous écoutent consonne voyelle
voyez excusez-moi
voyelles et consonnes
et voyelles
moyenne voyelles
voyelles
voyons
top 4 m quatre lettres cox pas bien loin
jcs
au
i e donc ce sera un bon présage pour
vous monsieur anciaux votre adversaire
aujourd'hui est un très jeune candidat
qui à 18 ans je crois les sept districts
qui s'appelle monsieur promène ses seins
romane qui équipent descendance
engagement l'origine c'est pratiquement
un match international quel est votre
jour d'hui pas votre profession de
qu'est-ce que vous faites aussi je suis
en mathématiques supérieures a donc un
bon point les jeunes c'est peut-être je
ne sais pas je savais pas
les mathématiques sont loin du calcul
mental bien monsieur bourdin il faut
vous décontracter le plus possible
essayez la forte partie faire affaire à
forte partie et je tiens je vais vous
demander tout de suite de choisir pile
ou face
ce
top monsieur gojira nous aide pas et ses
trousses cinq lettres pas mieux amis
s'inquiètent non non je ne dis pas on
les avait pris ces gentils disposition
la salle effectivement vous allez
trouver quoi monsieur match 2 c'était
quoi mur mur alors max c'est ce qu'on
pourrait trouver en cinq lettres là je
sais pas j'étais qu'avait olaf sur mes
genoux j'ai pas plus chercher
d'injection à ben alors tout va bien on
recommence dans la plus grande
décontraction et le score est maintenant
de 50 à 25 et madame du mais je suis
potter consonnes
et voyelles
aux voyelles
au hansson
consonne voyelle
aux
voyelles
[Musique]
je crois plus en resteront là que de
bâton ça vaut mieux pas
si facile de mener un peu embêtante le
score
madame du mais
heureusement d'ailleurs ce qui sous
marine au pop rock a été content et de
25 en faveur de mademoiselle barrois qui
n'a rien à perdre son mari n'est pas là
non monsieur fanion formique cette
moitié chien trouvé le chien l'a même si
heureuse
c'est parfaitement bon peut-être pas
très recommandé mais
il y avait bien public
allez-y monsieur
il y as me l'être avec active oh là là
mais bon allez vous chercher tout ça
avec van damme nos fenêtres avec
enculage au pluriel
enculage oui et des mouches
exclusivement
bien entendu
comme vous le voyez nous ne sommes pas
en vacances
et nos candidats sont là pour travailler
sérieusement n'est ce pas monsieur
renard
le geste suffit le châtelet s'agit bien
entendu vous venez pour la deuxième fois
et puis je dois dire que votre
adversaire ce soir s'appelle monsieur
carrie qui ribéry mais comme nous
n'avions pas ces deux lettres il faut le
dire face n'était pas assez grand il
s'appellera monsieur karim et
j'essaierai de prononcer votre nom le
plus souvent possible je vous fais
plaisir de vous y mettre même si vous
venez vous perdre mes erreurs le compte
est bon
8 et 6 13
qu'est ce que vous
avez dit
madame je
regarde tout va bien pour vous
non mais je veux dire en général vous
êtes content d'être avec nom de lord
effectivement tout à fait content en
fait
tous les coupés les cheveux même
batterie
s'est entraîné toute la semaine va
porter ce lourd bouclier va remettre ce
bouclier à me bousquet qui va le
remettre au nom de la ville de nîmes à
notre vainqueur de ce soir ce bousquet
il peut descendre je pense
voilà
c'est l'oeuvre de
l'artisan de saint jean du gard ces deux
gladiateurs puisqu'ils viennent un vase
de romain du musée de nîmes donc voilà
on est ravi de notre notre premier nom
sur ce bouclier
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir m'a dit
qu'il fallait que ce soit un peu plus
moderne dont j'ai essayé je passe sur ça
et biot ça vous plaît ou pas non je
reste non je resterai train c'est parce
que vous avez présenté leur vision oui
ça m'a donné des envies des variétés
comme ça je m'en suis pas sûr que ce
soit vraiment le style de l'émission
[Musique]
je tiens vous y verrez comme un
chevalier fortement perturbé ou l'avait
vu d'ailleurs sur son visage par cette
nouvelle musique qui accompagne notre
générique est vraiment maxi siyassa vous
savez j'ai été pris de court absolue
je signale au réalisateur au camas
aurélie fera peut-être des erreurs qu'on
émission c'est à cause de cette de 30
lavalas nous allons très rapidement
passer au match qui oppose malam du rif
monsieur note noté j'espère que je ne
verrai pas possible n'a pas l'accent ce
marquez votre nom mais apparemment je
vais faire les choses que je n'ai jamais
fait en public une chose qu'à des
lunettes parce que j'aurai et j'étais
bien normal d'ailleurs la plupart
d'entre eux doit être au courant rendra
un hommage à max avaler vous savez que
maxwell est l'une des plus dans son
fauteuil et cette fois ci il ne s'agit
plus d'une escapade mais d'un vrai
départ
max a en effet décidé posco la coutume
d'appeler les raisons personnelles de
prendre congé des chiffres et des
lettres alors je vous rassure tout de
suite qu'il va très bien et continuera
d'ailleurs à dire ses différentes
activités
mais je suis sûr qu'il va nous manquer
terriblement car personne et surtout pas
moi deux poignées combien il a marqué
depuis 13 ans cette émission de sa
personnalité célèbre cocktail de
bonhomie de gentillesse d'humour et
d'érudition et je n'ai pas peur de dire
qu'il était un peu notre maître de vie
et que même ceux qui lui reprochaient
quelquefois certains excès prends mon
très vite conscience de la place
importante qu'il tenait dans cette
émission il a voulu se retirer sans
flonflon sur la pointe des pieds nus on
voulait pas nous ne voulons pas
d'ailleurs la pudeur fait aussi partie
de son personnage alors au nom de toute
l'équipe je t'adresse mon cher max un
grand salut et à tout de suite dans
d'autres lieux plus propice aux
débordements amicaux voilà
tu pouvais vu quand même max parti c'est
quand même une page contourne
yvette alors vous allez assurer
l'intérim à mes proches alentours du rac
terry s'est saignée qui va remplacer max
on se prend ne sais pas encore parce que
ça a été une décision assez rapide et on
ne s'est pas tu as encore donc on attend
en cours suite à et puis comme on dit le
show must go c'est à dire que le
spectacle continue vous ne vous êtes me
tromper ni de chaînes ni de jeu ce sont
bien les chiffres et les lettres vous
êtes bien sur antenne 2 nous avons
quelque peu changé de look parce que
peut-être que c'est le printemps il
fallait un certain rajeunissement
laurent mangel mois décidé de apporté
quelques modifications à ce jeu vous
allez voir elles sont très simples
surtout dans le décor et puis je vais
vous présenter quelqu'un qui va
dorénavant remplacer joe frachon qui
chez lui d'ailleurs que je salue mon
petit jo toutes nos amitiés c'est une
jeune femme c'est une jeune femme que
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir je
vous demande d'applaudir d'ailleurs ça
va la mettre en confiance
elle s'appelle ariel c'est bien ça ariel
boulin prat exactement ariel je n'aurais
pas je ne veux pas vous demander votre
âge ça ne se fait pas
vous avez quand même métier je suppose
oui je suis professeur de lettres de
lettres classiques donc normalement les
lettres vous connaissez je ne connais
pas tout mais je vais faire de mon mieux
aya nous accueillons avec plaisir dans
cette émission je pense que le public va
faire de même pas trop le trac ça va ça
va alors on va faire comme sur une
chaîne concurrente et dans mois et demi
voile je vous emmène jusqu'à votre table
vous retrouvez le prochain candidat et
bertrand soyez sages avec lui un
phénomène le compte est bon
car +37
50 mois 7 43 3 75 qu'elle soit 43 645
je n'ai pas repris comme chez le
fabricant avait déjà enlevé son micro il
se dit je m'en vais déjà
effectivement malheureusement vous allez
pour vous ne vais pas rester avec nous
puisque monsieur lendemain après un très
beau match de votre part avec craquer
sur une faute et ça suffit pour perdre
et de toute façon j'aurais perdu
pourquoi au niveau de vous le dire avant
la préfère 954 non si j'avais mal quand
à prochain
vous avez perdu au tirage en a perdu
alors moindre regret monsieur lendemain
qui vient d'emporter sa deuxième
victoire en lever toujours pas votre vie
cours monsieur fabrigoule parce que je
vais aller vers vous vous êtes pressé là
il ya un problème et je vais vous
remettre
le jeu électronique des chiffres et des
lettres le voilà merci monsieur
labrecque vole mon retour chez vous
monsieur landemaine nouveaux gars
conservons parmi nous mais je me suis
fabriqué ce qui se passe et
nationalistes vous avez un train ou quoi
vos sites favoris gaulle j'étais bien je
vais rester à côté parce qu'ils ne
partent pas avant la fin de l'émission
et je le sers bien non il ne partira pas
bonsoir à tous et merci et je ne veux
pas terminer sans dire que c'est avec
une grande émotion je crois que tous les
téléspectateurs vont voir patrice
laffont quitter sa démission qui les
animait goût de talent il à nouveau ce
soir prouvé avec quel brio il pouvait
diriger ce plat tout remarquable nous
sommes heureux que leurs encadreurs et
accepter dû succéder mais nous
regrettons beaucoup que patrice tôt
quitte effectivement je vais demander à
toute l'équipe de vire
bon ça m'a un peu difficile mais c'est
le surmonter bien un des armes en
devenir effectivement il est temps pour
moi de tourner la page est tournée la
page ça veut dire quelques merci alors
je voudrais d'abord dire merci
je vais y arriver je vais je prends mon
souffle à tous les téléspectateurs qui
tiennent qui met pas beaucoup patrice
laffont il y en avait un il existait et
devoir supporter pendant 17 ans c'est
déjà bien merci infiniment tous ses
téléspectateurs
merci à ceux qui mord au contraire
encouragé qui m'appelait leur petit-fils
leur phase était d'aider chose de très
très formidable je dirais je pense
particulièrement à une dame je crois que
ça lui fera plaisir je peux faire un
petit hommage particulier qui s'appelle
odette un voile à odette ce soir elle
doit être je sais qu'en dehors quelques
larmes alors d'être ne pleure pas ça se
passera très bien et puis j'aimerais
aussi bon il est là à côté de moi je
serais déjà dit autrement
qu'on va dire merci infinie armand
jammot parce que c'est grâce à lui que
je fais de la télévision et que c'est un
métier merveilleux que j'espère
continuer j'espère continuer à pratiquer
sur antenne 2 d'ailleurs on a entendu
bon d'accord voilà
merci aussi
à tous cette équipe avec qui j'ai vécu
des moments formidables et même d'un
certain moment quand je le disais or
c'est un peu astreignants cela peut
aller enregistrer bond et c'est en
souhaitant entendra les petits creux et
ben on se retrouve et puis j'ai retrouvé
la petite bénédicte bertrand arguel eelv
est on était tous là et puis ont déjeuné
ensemble rigoler puis la journée passait
bien et puis encore envie de se
retrouver le mardi après c'est ce qu'on
a fait depuis longtemps et qu'on
continuera à faire même si l'émission 1
d'accord il serments trahis balles mardi
le lundi walter
voilà et bien maintenant je
vous quitte les je vais demander à mon
successeur que j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur cette scène à laurent
cabrol de bien vouloir venir nous
rejoindre vous la police et
alors je m'étais promis quelque chose je
vais te
dépasser si j'y arrive à l'angle ainsi
numéro 1 de façon à ce que tu n'es pas
les deux pieds dans le même sabot qu'est
ce qui va la chercher voilà c'est le
sait laisser le témoignage ça c'est le
sabot que les joueurs connaissent mal
d'ailleurs tu vois là dedans y aller et
voyelles une console voilà nourrir les
voyelles c'est ainsi que l'on cherche et
potions micro exactement c'est ainsi que
l'on tire donc les voyelles oui mais tu
le sais déjà dès demain on te retrouves
à la lame et monsieur moi simplement je
voulais vous dire que dès demain à 18h45
le jeu continue l'équipe est toujours la
patrie sera toujours parmi nous nous
espérons qu'il viendra nous voir de
temps en temps bon bah demain dès 8h45
les chiffres et les lettres nous serons
tous là toute l'équipe et j'essaierai
j'essaierai de remplacer patrie je sais
que ce n'est pas toujours facile mais
soyez indulgents pendant les premiers
jours et ensuite ça ira beaucoup mieux
je voulais simplement un dernier mot
très honnêtement vous fassiez novation à
patrice c'est lui qui a porté les
missions pendant des années et je tiens
absolument à ce nous fasse une ovation
et j'ai le très grand plaisir de vous
présenter le petit nouveau petits
nouveaux on peut le dire parce qu il a
28 ans donc il est tout jeune c'est
laurent romejko
bonjour leur ventre mais je vous laisse
le fauteuil qui vous revient merci merci
bonjour à toutes et à tous ici dans ce
public il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de monde rassemblé dans
cette salle du palais des congrès
d'antibes juan les pins et moi c'est ma
première coupe des clubs c'est aussi ma
première émission alors avant toute
chose je tenais à dresser quelques
remerciements des remerciements tout
d'abord à l'ensemble de l'équipe des
chiffres et des lettres tout
particulièrement élevé de plailly ariel
boulin prat ar lenn bertrand renard et
puis bien entendu armand jammot à merci
également à mon prédécesseur max meynier
qui hier dans cette émission est bien
m'a adressé ses voeux de réussite et je
tiens à le remercier laurent il ya une
petite chose encore qu'il faut dire
comme nous l'a rappelé ces jours-ci
notre producteur armand jammot nous
avons un anniversaire à fêter
figurez-vous à la caisse ces nouveaux
trains
mais oui ça fait un an
ça fait un an que vous posiez votre
entrée parmi nous c'est un an que vous
et votre andré parmi nous et maintenant
vous avez grandi dans la fidélité des
téléspectateurs beaucoup plus que bien
des animateurs alors donc pour fêter cet
anniversaire et pour fêter toutes les
années vous allez encore grandir plus et
ben champagne t exactement le champagne
locale
voilà vous versez et la dissoudre
d'applaudissements
merci gérard de quoi me rafraîchir
durant ses 27 minutes d'émission
[Musique]